scientists around the world are racing
to complete testing
of coronavirus vaccines and we have an
inside look
at the final phase of development two
u.s pharmaceutical giants pfizer and
moderna are in this
phase three oxford university is
expected to start its trials in the u.s
this month
our chief medical correspondent dr john
lapook shows what it's like
to be part of the pfizer trial
i wanted to be part of the solution
for dr victoria smith who practices
family medicine near new orleans
covid19 is personal she's lost
three patients to the virus i'm not an
immunologist
but by being part of a trial i can be
part of that research front as well
in late july dr smith became one of the
first of thirty thousand participants
needed for pfizer's phase three vaccine
me she trials her first dose at ochsner
medical center in louisiana
it's a double-blinded study meaning
neither she nor the researchers know
whether she received the vaccine
or a placebo are you kind of hoping you
got the vaccine
do cbs news got an exclusive look at
ochsner's phase 3 trial site
every week pfizer sends them packages of
the vaccine and placebo
the vaccine is then stored in this
freezer at a temperature of at least
minus 60 degrees celsius to remain
stable
this vaccine is new did that give you
any pause
not really i trust the process to be
approved by the fda a covet 19
vaccine must prevent or decrease the
severity of the disease in at least 50
percent of vaccinated people
there's no evidence that that the
vaccine makes
the disease worse at all so that's
really really ensuring in
very encouraging dr catherine edwards is
on pfizer's vaccine safety board
once a week the five members of the
committee video chat to carefully look
through data for adverse effects
especially serious ones such as
hospitalizations so we're very very
cautious
in how we look at the data certainly if
there were a severe reaction we would
get that information right away
dr edwards says there is no evidence so
far the vaccine causes serious reactions
but that mild reactions are common and
should not deter
anyone from getting vaccinated you may
have a sore arm or you may have a little
tenderness or
or you may have a little headache or you
may have a little fever
so those are things to be expected it's
just your immune system getting tweaked
and you're making a better response
trial participants are required to
self-monitor and log their symptoms on
an app reporting their temperature and
any reactions daily for a week after
each injection
log it into my phone they will then
continue to log any symptoms on a weekly
basis for two years
on wednesday after 21 days dr smith
received her final dose
early trial results show a second shot
boosts neutralizing antibodies that
block the viruses ability to attack
our bodies if you look at the immune
responses
into in the people that got one dose in
two the two doses their immune response
was higher
so i think that they're probably going
to need two doses
but a vaccine is not expected to mean an
immediate return
to the way things were if the vaccine's
50
effective it's not going to reduce all
the disease
you know social distancing the mass
these things may need to continue
and people will continue to need to have
some
thought about what their activities have
and the implications that they have
for the rest of the community and dr
john lapook joins us now good morning
john
john there have been some issues i i
gather regarding enrolling enough
volunteers for the vaccine trials
particularly among
minorities how is that affecting this
good morning anthony as you know coven
19 has been disproportionately affecting
african americans latinx native
americans and pacific islanders
so it's very important that these
communities are well represented in the
trials
but i spoke to dr francis collins a few
days ago he's the head of the national
institutes of health as you know and he
said
that that's not happening that these
communities are underrepresented and in
fact he said
he was hoping that some prominent
members of these communities perhaps
even some celebrities would step forward
and volunteer to serve as an example
that's one of the reasons why i was so
impressed with dr
smith who is the physician who we
featured in our piece today because she
said that one of the reasons she took
the vaccine was to serve as an example
for patients many of whom
are black and latinx yeah but you i wish
you could have seen gail squirm when she
got the shot
i know i know that with gail
all right john thank you